[Music]
boom what's up everyone welcome to
simulation I'm your host I'll sake on
very excited to be talking about helping
men evolve we have dr. John sinner
joining us on the show hello hello thank
you so much for coming on really
appreciate it
my pleasure thanks for having me I'm
super pumped this is gonna be a lit for
those that don't know dr. John sinner
holds a PhD in educational psychology
from UC Berkeley he served as one of
three expert consultants for Pixar's
inside out he is host of the evolved
caveman podcast teaching the latest
tools for men's happiness and success
relationships leadership communication
physical health and business find all
the links in the bio below to guide to
self.com the evolved caveman calm as
well as his LinkedIn Twitter and
Instagram profiles all right John let's
start things off with one of our
favorite questions to ask our guests
what are your thoughts on the direction
of our world
all right direction of world I guess in
general I'm concerned I think there's
some good and some bad out there I think
I'm encouraged by certain movements that
are happening out there positive
psychology appreciative inquiry I see
more volunteerism and a younger
generation all that's good stuff and
then on the flip side on the other hand
I think that I see a lot more anger than
I've ever seen you know as someone who
specializes in anger management I just
see it in our political parties I see it
and how polarized we are I see it and
how inflexible our thinking is and how
we want to demonize others and so I'm
concerned that if we don't get a handle
on our own emotional state that we're
going to be in trouble and this is why
you care so much about getting the
handle on the emotional state yeah damn
damn yep the Machir amount of lack of
really wanting to get to people's hearts
and wanting to ask some questions to
understand them and how they got to
their perspective versus the reactive
anger immediately you're a worldview
doesn't align with mine too bad yeah
it's over that's it so this to be able
to dive into humans deeper there's
something to get really fast about okay
so then we're gonna unpack some of these
principles about how to do this
our conversation that you've been
formulating and teaching people along
the way let's do the journey okay okay
so born in the Bay Area and Walnut Creek
and then I want to know how did you get
hooked into psychology in your younger
years okay so I come from a strong
German family with two parents that are
successful overachieving kind of they're
driven and so I learned from a young age
that in order to get their attention and
their love at least from my perspective
I also needed to be hard driving
overachieving driven and it led to me as
a senior in high school I was I guess
killing it from the outside I would
played you know I was captain of three
varsity teams I was student body
president I was taking AP courses and
I'm sure from the outside people thought
wow from the inside however it was a
much different experience I was stressed
a lot I was anxious a lot I was
depressed part of the time I was sick a
lot as a result of that and it caused me
to question this whole idea of success
at the age of 17 like what is this
success because I'm not feeling it right
now like where's there room for
happiness or relaxation or contentment
and you know it it worked it got me into
a really great college I went to Pomona
College and I kept going back to this
idea of where's there room for happiness
and I majored in philosophy which
prepared a joke prepared me to do
absolutely nothing but interestingly it
kind of came full circle 20 years later
because with positive psychology they're
really concerned with answering that
question that Aristotle asked thousands
of years ago what is the good life it
took me a while to figure that out but
in any case you know I got into UC
Berkeley and a ph.d program in
psychology and one of the reasons
psychology interested me was because I
knew that I had been a pretty smart kid
growing up but where I got hamstrung was
with my emotions I've always been
someone that feels things deeply and I
was really confused by these
emotions that I couldn't quite manage
and so I got into psychology really with
the selfish interest of how do I manage
myself and how was all about cognitive
psychology so it's all about how we
think so I had to actually wait till I
got out of cow to do more research on
emotion and you know I remember I was a
school psychologist I was probably 26 27
and no one really prepares you for
getting into the field in the sense that
most of us that get into the field are
empathetic and so you pick up people's
emotions quite easily and readily and if
you're dealing with people that are
depressed or anxious or angry guess what
you pick up their emotions and so it
ended with me I remember I was in my
office I got depressed because I was
just hearing these heavy stories over
and over again when you're depressed the
inflammation your body goes up so my
back goes out so I'm in pain I'm
depressed I'm like okay this makes no
sense like Here I am a psych trained at
Cal and I can't manage my own emotions
if I can't do it who can and how do I
teach them to so at that point I started
looking for the best scientifically
proven tools cuz that's my background
from Cal to manage that darker side of
the mind mainly fear anger sadness guilt
shame and and it worked that was you
know part of the equation it was helpful
it wasn't the whole thing fast forward I
got into an entrepreneurial venture that
did well for a bit and then failed
I had to reinvent myself and at that
point I started getting into positive
psychology which is basically the
scientific study of human happiness and
that was life-changing I mean it was
like manna from heaven it was amazing
and I thought wow you know now I've got
tools to turn down the volume on the
negative turn up the volume on the
positive this is powerful I need to
share this so I started sort of
compulsively writing I wrote a like 600
page rough draft of a book of how to
coach people towards a successful and
happy life happen to go to a Christian
businessman networking breakfast in the
city happened to sit next to a guy who
owned a radio station and you know
Christian networking events kind of a
weird place for me because I consider
myself spiritual
not a big fan of organized religion so
you know I believe in a higher power I
just don't like other people really
telling me how to do X I've throughout
the years found flaws and what they're
saying generally anyways we I met a few
times with this guy and he said John I
want to put you on the air I want to
give you your own show and I thought oh
[ __ ]
the thought terrified me because it was
a huge radio signal it reached 10
million people it was a daily primetime
live show that he was talking about but
I also knew when you're dealing with
anxiety that you have to go after it
like that's the best way to deal with it
so I said sure did a radio show was not
very good at the beginning was pretty
stiff learned how to kind of tell a
story in a mote and tell a joke in a
vacuum
and got better at it got to interview
some world-class experts and then after
a year opened up private practice and
you know I opened up with a positive
psychology kind of focus which was I
kind of got a lukewarm response and I
talked to a psychiatrist friend of mine
and he was like well you know what we
really needed someone to do anger
management in the valley that's like how
I can do that and I thought all I'll
combine anger management with positive
psychology because if you're trying to
you know reduce the frequency of anger
it's my belief you need something to put
in its place
and I would say that's positive emotions
positive thoughts you know and and so
things started picking up I created this
online anger management class and
initially it was for men because the
people guiding me said find a niche I'm
like well there's got to be millions of
men out there that need these tools but
maybe aren't brave enough to come in and
see someone or don't have the money to
come see someone weekly or aren't nearby
mm-hmm a couple of things that happened
it happened that we're kind of funny as
soon as I went live with that I start
getting hundreds of emails from angry
women all around the world well and they
were like hey buddy we're pissed off too
what about us I was like it's not a it's
not personal like it wasn't about you
like they told me fine you know it's
like so it's kind of backtracking and so
I had to make it gender neutral and then
the other thing that was pretty
fascinating is I got this email and this
was I don't know eight years ago and
said dear doctor Shin er er
been in prison for 27 years been
addicted to meth and PCP for as long I
no longer wish to be the man I once was
turned my life around six years ago
thanks for the free anger classes why
profound and I was like yes so I don't
know who this guy is right so I just you
know fire off a email hey good job
turning your life around keep up the
good work
I go to see a client I come back there's
a response from him within an hour I'm
like what's up like who has email access
in prison he says Dear John this isn't
my real name my handlers won't let me
use my real name check out the books the
black hand in urban street terrorism
that's me once you do a little research
I'm sure you'll understand why I was
like okay this guy's really good because
now I'm hooked I'm curious so I check
out the book the black hand it's about
this guy Rene Boxer Enriquez who is
involved in the Mexican Mafia and I
think he got out of it you know six
years prior so I got to work with him
for a while which was a fascinating
story in and of itself and created a
little anxiety in me as well anyway I
won't go too far into but so I want to I
want to plan a couple things as we got
to where we're at so one of the things
that you're talking about earlier is
like immediately going from the PhD in
educational psychology into school
counseling and then realizing that now
you're taking on the load of tons of
different various emotional states of
young people on a daily basis one after
the other and like are we actually
trained for that is like a great
question and how do we actually balance
these tools like you said cause of
psychology anger management how do we I
mean only later did you really start
like unpacking these tools and better
understanding that ok so then I'm give
us the bit on positive psychology and
anger management and how they've been
relating to the clients that you've now
been working with and seeing especially
the men
okay so typically when I see
I'll see male adolescents or male
businessmen and they're coming in with
some degree of stress or some degree of
anger irritability is a common one and
so part of it is teaching them about
anger for instance you know one of the
first places I'll go is breaking down
anger to three different spectrums or
axes so you know if you think of what's
the diff di F you've got duration
intensity frequency so duration how long
does it last when you get angry or you
is it three minutes is it three hours is
it three decades because we can hold
onto grudges pretty well too I is
intensity that's normally how we think
of an emotion so think of it on a 1 to
10 scale with 1 being calm and 10 being
Incredible Hulk enraged and you know so
how intense is it getting when you're
getting angry and then frequency how
often does it come up and so you you
know as you begin to kind of parse it
out you can look for improvement on any
one of those areas and then part of it
is relaxation exercises stress
management techniques part of it is
finding out what your triggers are and
being aware of those in the moment part
of it I think is spending more time in
the present moment because most of us go
through life as an automaton we're kind
of on autopilot and we're not really
aware of our inner processes and what
drives us and we are truly creatures of
habit and those habits can be good or
bad most of them are just you know I
mean like if you think about drinking
you know I remember I was dating a woman
a while back and she was sober and it
caused me to look at my drinking oh yeah
and I would reach for a vodka soda and
I'd be like do I really need this like
why am i drinking this what am I getting
out of this and you know so that kind of
process of just awareness in the moment
of why am I doing this
reap at earning habits that way when you
surround yourself with people that are
countercultural in a sense it gives you
another layer of insight into your own
you have patterns and behaviors yeah and
so then you know I I pulled in the
positive psychology piece because my
belief is when you when you start to
reduce the intensity frequency and
duration of something like anger it
creates a vac
and if you don't find something else to
put in though the anger comes back oh
whoa okay okay the increase of vacuum so
when when I have a adoration of anger
that moves from three hours to one hour
mm-hmm there's of you there needs to be
something that fills the other two hours
so I yeah that linearise but it's what
I'm feeling what you're yeah what you're
putting down there and so then how does
one then work with positive psychology
with that anger management practice and
so there's a I mean you know there's
three pages of tools to you know kind of
answer that question but in general you
know one of the pieces is learning what
the positive emotions are so that you
can be better at spotting them in the
present moment and savoring them in
other words extending them in time yeah
so for instance you know we know that
positive emotions are fleeting and
fragile yeah which means that they don't
last long they're quiet
and if you overthink them they go away
and you know we know that the negative
emotions are loud they scream at us
right so you know when you have a
problem but you don't necessarily know
when you're relaxed a lot of times we'll
go mmm I'm tired hmm
you don't really have much recognition
of when you're feeling aw or elevation
you know when when you see someone else
do an act of moral courage it kind of
gives us this feeling of a swelling in
the chest the shoulders pull back chin
goes up and we're inspired watching
someone else's moral courage so it's you
know there's a number of positive
emotions that we can be aware of and
learn to look for and cultivate or
create the conditions to experience them
more frequently in our lives and there's
I mean there's meaning there's
relationships there's there's a number
of aspects to this but that's one aspect
that's excellent so it's having this
meta perspective on the body on the
feeling and so to be able to see that
from from a third-person perspective
okay there's the anger that's being
triggered now how long is this anger
gonna stay here you might really aware
of this anger same thing with that if I
feel something that's super profoundly
positive if I'm really in a deep state
of flow can I take a quick moment to
look at myself
flow and be like wow okay this is when
you know you talk about flow state like
if you're in a flow state whether you're
playing guitar or you know jumping a
bike off a 30-foot jump if you stop to
think oh I'm in flow State or why am I
so happy you or why am I not thinking it
goes away yeah and and so part of this
becomes I think you know learning and
cultivating the skill of mindfulness you
know I see meditation on your wall here
that we need to spend more time we need
to train our minds to spend more time in
the present moment because there's
there's some early research that shows
that we spend more than half of our time
in the past in the future and that
wandering mind is associated with more
misery damn if 50% of our time is spent
in the future in the past that's nuts
well because normally we go to a
negative past or negative future it's
not we don't go to a positive past in a
positive future generally we're going to
negative on both and that yeah because
if we're going to a positive future
that's that future authoring that we
want to keep with us right on a
moment-to-moment basis even in the
present okay that's this is this has
been so so fascinating already let's do
okay on the way to getting to the
evolved caveman I want to hit on
consulting for inside out okay because I
think there's something about the way
that we are disseminating multimedia
content that needs the that needs the
really strong storyteller scientists
philosophers the people that can help
make sure that when the content gets
disseminated that it really resonates
with people that it that kind of stuff
so teach us about what this process was
like with Pixar well you know it's I
mentioned that online anger management
class I've always been a gig and you
know I've been able to program computers
and so it's 12 so I could throw up
websites and blogs and I got my SEO
pretty good for anger management so when
I did that online video course it would
come up high so when Pixar needed
someone on anger management I guess they
found me online and I see you as that
character right now the one that's they
have and so I get this call one day and
she says hey this is an executive
assistant here at Pixar could you speak
to a producer here
like yeah like I'm thinking maybe he's
stressed or depressed I don't know and
so he gets on the phone he said say this
is Jonas Rivera I'm a producer here at
Pixar I'd produced this movie called up
maybe you're familiar with it I'm like
trying to be cool like yeah I've heard
of it and I knew I owned it right I had
the movie at home because I have four
kids so I knew damn well I owned it and
I'm like and I love Pixar so I was like
yeah yeah I think I've heard of it and
it's like oh good well he said me and
Pete dr.p directed up we're working on a
new project and we're wondering if you'd
come down and kind of kick some ideas
around and brainstorm with us I was like
oh yeah I think I can fit that in my
calendar pretty much any time and so I
got to go down there and and it was
funny because you go in and you get this
tag and you know it's got the aliens
from Toy Story on system woo a visitor
from the outside and I was just geeking
out on all this and there's this when
you go into the Pixar campus there's a
building over here to the right where
most visitors go and they've got huge 3d
statues of all their characters and then
there's the Brooklyn building and I
remember I was told to go to the
Brooklyn building so I'm walking there
and the security guard stops me says you
know excuse me sir are you lost you know
do you do you need some help and I said
well I'm I have a meeting at the
Brooklyn Building is like oh okay well
going in and I was like so I go in and
ei meets me at the door and there's you
know a staircase and there's a the
staircase is roped off and says no one
up the staircase without producer
accompaniment yeah yeah and so we go
right up the staircase we go into a room
where there's you know concept art for
inside out and you know I think Jonah's
me met me in there and we're looking at
the the characters and I was like okay I
see sadness I see joy I see anger not
really sure what you're doing with that
one and it was discussed it was like a
huge nose it was kind of turned up and
so they they had some issues with two of
the characters which we you know which I
just picked out and said not sure about
those and then we spent a day with their
top 12 people on the movie just
discussing anger and emotion
and the neuroscience behind it nice and
it was it was incredible these guys had
done so much foundational research
before I had even gotten in the room I
was blown away and and so just to have
it just have a hand in any Pixar film
was really really flattering that one in
particular I think has done a tremendous
job of educating a generation of kids
that we have voices in our head the
voices don't always make sense that we
have emotions the emotions don't always
make sense and to work to accept them
and to be able to label them and give
them a language to talk about them in
which i think is immensely valuable yes
yes didn't like you said the amount of
research that was done even before
you're getting in there there there were
12 people that were already working on
this day I'd already under the built out
the characters had built out like
corpuses of knowledge on every single
one of them so and that's why it
resonates so deeply for it for again
this for the dissemination of it and
then like you said it's just so critical
that then we have these a deeper
understanding of double-clicking into
the emotions within our bodies thanks to
content like this so what a what a what
a cool I really look forward to more
content that enriches us like that
that's like high signal content and I'm
obsessed with high signal it doesn't get
any better in my mind I mean because
it's entertaining and educational and
it's entertaining and it at a level I
mean I like I remember I went into this
meeting and I said you know it's kind of
funny to me that you want to talk to me
and you want me to teach you about
emotion because you guys are the best in
the world at evoking emotion and others
mm-hmm you know I think I should be
sitting here picking your brains what do
I have to teach you I don't know I'll
give it a shot
but yeah so cool that you got to do that
all right
let's do let's go into some of the
assets we have for helping men evolve
okay so there's a question yes right
okay is there any room for negative
energy or anger and
new world ahead of us absolutely I mean
you know one of the things that I'll
talk about with clients is we're not the
goal is not to eliminate anger
the goal is to feel anger to be aware of
it in the moment and to use that to
assert yourself ideally in a calm way to
state your needs but I mean without
anger I mean think of all the social
justice movements in the world like
without anger none of those exist
without anger we get walked all over
mm-hmm without anger we're not alerted
when our boundaries are trespassed so
anger serves a very important function
all emotions do it's just that we're
very crude at how we handle our anger
we're cavemen yeah yeah this is well
said serve such important purpose but
we're kind of crude and yeah cavemen
still yeah this kind of the the
Paleolithic understanding of our bodies
and biologies and neurophysiologists all
its stuff versus the today's day and age
with the information technology and the
news feed and algorithms they're just
incompatible right yeah yeah and one of
the things if I can loop back to this
because one of the dynamics that I see
with anger that really concerns me is
you know I work with a lot of men that
that are angry and anger when you're
angry if we're in an argument and we're
really angry at each other it's none of
it's my fault
anger is all about externalizing blame
and so if you think about that and you
play that out and you've got men that
are chronically irritable
nothing's their fault they don't need to
change a thing the problem is with
everyone else out there and if the world
would just change or if women would just
change or protected groups would just
change I'd be okay and it's a very
unrealistic approach it shuts down
learning and and so I think once you
become aware of that dynamic it can help
you to get out of it the other thing
that I talk to a lot of people about is
if we're in an argument and we're
raising our voices and starting to yell
at each other nothing I say is going to
get into your head and nothing you say
is going to get into my
so the point of arguing it that you know
when you're really getting escalated
above a five on that intensity scale
it's pointless
at some point and so when you realize
that - it's like okay I need to work to
bring it down so that I can potentially
influence you to see my what I'm talking
about
mm-hmm yeah and just taking the break to
go walk outside and stuff like that all
different types of things work out
yeah deeply deeply you frame yep yep yep
this is so critical let's we have some
great assets okay let's let's pull him
up because this also has to do with that
him history so let's do the first one
Ronny okay so how men are socialized
yeah so walk us through this okay so
back in the 1980s Paul kibble was doing
some work in Oakland with men that had
engaged in domestic violence and he
started asking them questions about what
their experience was like growing up as
a man and he found some commonalities
and part of it is that were were
socialized to be invulnerable or
socialized not to feel were socialized
to dominate women to be aggressive to
not back down there's a number of things
to it but the way that's done is this
man box culture where generally men
police themselves we're policing
ourselves and you know growing up a lot
it for a lot of men it's their dad
that's saying this stuff if it's not
your dad if you were lucky and your dad
was pretty cool and had a more open
mindset I guess then it's your friends
if it's not your friends it could be a
sports coach it could be a teacher
it could even be females around you I've
had you know teenage clients recently
that you know they'll one guy said he
was crying in front of his girlfriend
and his girlfriend said stop being such
a [ __ ] but we get these insults of you
know man up stop being a little [ __ ]
don't be a [ __ ] don't be a [ __ ] don't be
so gay and these things have been around
for since I was a kid and I you know
tell my clients when they come in like
look if you think back to your childhood
I can effectively eliminate two-thirds
of the emotional spectrum for you with
two phrases if you show too much sadness
or fear stop being a [ __ ]
bang gone if you're smart if you're
sensitive you learned that lesson real
quick we don't like to be humiliated we
don't want to be embarrassed and we'll
pick that up fast then if you show too
much excitement joy love Romanticism
don't be so gay so what are we left with
as men were left with primarily anger
some degree of anger annoyance
irritation rage and then you know I
would say there's also we can cop to
stress because I can be I can use stress
to show how successful I am look how
busy I am I'm stressed and then I think
there's also something like lust in
their butt so everything that we feel
gets channeled and redirected through
the lens of anger damn are the so on
everything kind of like emotionally
connecting to others let's say is kind
of like on the don't be the [ __ ] side
and then everything on the on the like
maybe a another way of saying it's maybe
on the like I'm connecting to sunsets or
something I'm connecting and don't be so
gay so so there's like wow that
eliminates so much so that programming
at such a young age in culture literally
see ult cult sure right that that is
what programming has cost some of the
megalomaniacs some of the psychopathy
that we have today neurosis in men yeah
I don't know if it's caused it I mean I
think it's exacerbated it exacerbated it
sort of it I think it's biological or
totally organic plays it plays a big
role in it yeah um would you would you
this is the man box culture right yeah
so you call this the the bot where it's
like you can't feel don't feel that what
you're feeling about the sunset right
now or are you about to cry because you
feel something when you don't feel that
that's outside the box right as soon as
we step outside the box and show
behavior that you know another man
doesn't like or is uncomfortable with
they'll insult you to get you to jump
back in the box yeah yeah yes that's
that that's the feedback mechanism is
that we're the way we're socialized were
not socialized to learn to communicate
we're not socialized to learn to be
emotionally aware we're not socialized
to be empathetic and so then you fast
forward 20 years 30 years and
you're in a relationship and I mean if
you're if you're straight the women that
we're with are like I can't connect with
my man like let's bring them pathetic
he's not communicative let's bring up
the next asset for this part okay yeah
so this is yeah yeah go ahead go ahead
and and so back in the day you know it
used to be sufficient to be a good
provider to not drink too much don't do
drugs and don't hit anybody that was a
good husband now the the expectations
the job definition for husband has
changed dramatically we're you know
women are looking for someone that
sympathetic empathetic communicative
emotionally aware and they're confused
as to why they're not getting it but the
job definition changed for us and nobody
told us and and on top of that we've
been socialized in exactly the opposite
way so now we're in these relationships
and our women are unsatisfied and you
know we're pretty easily
you know placated or we're more easily
satisfied so if they were satisfied we'd
be okay but they're not and so I really
think that we're at a point where if we
don't learn to evolve as men if we don't
begin to learn some new skills and learn
some open-mindedness you know it might
be a bit of an exaggeration but I think
we run the risk of being superfluous
because you know that this change
happened because women start getting out
into the workforce yeah making more
money there's more political power there
and while it's still not even they don't
need us as much for that financial
arrangement that used to be marriage and
so they're looking for more in a partner
they're demanding more and you know it's
funny I've had this conversation before
with with certain men and a lot of men
will get triggered and start they get
angry and they'll be like well how come
I have to change like why don't why
don't the women change it's like well
unfortunately they already have yeah
they're already upgrade now a clean
catch yeah so you know it's it's on us
to up our game and up our skills and all
these are learnable skills yeah yeah
give us some some of the key strategies
for the 2019
emotional intelligence attributes that
we can be gaining in order to be better
well one of the things I mean I think
you know when I was younger I used to
you know as I said I was smart so I a
lot of my identity was wrapped up in my
thoughts and you know I was up here a
lot in my head and what I found some
years later embarrassingly is that
emotions are embodied so they're mostly
in our body from the head down and you
know Descartes really screwed us several
hundred years ago when he said I think
therefore I am
because that statement essentially
separated mind from body and you know I
was a big fan of that statement when I
was in college and it took me a while to
unlearn that and realize okay wait I
gotta slow down and tune in to what's
going on in my body
what's my heart rate doing that's when
you also flash and think therefore I am
yeah and you know what's my jaw doing
like are my thoughts over focusing on
angry things you know am i perspiring
like and and so you can look at these
physiological cues and one of the things
I've got it my office is a an emotion
map where they ask 800 people to color
in on a computer where do you experience
in the body anger fear sadness anxiety
pride happiness and you can see these
patterns very quickly and where do
people experience so where do you find
the patterns here well anger I mean to
me anger is it can be in the fists
because anger is preparing you to attack
so your blood rushes to your fists and
your feet you might some people get
muscle tension in their forearm the
jawed generally gets tight you the heart
rate goes up that's my biggest tell that
there's a negative emotion kind of
coming up that you know the heart rate
will go up and and so it's it's things
like that that really help you to
identify what you're feeling in the
moment the problem is you have to be in
the present moment your attention has to
be there in order to catch it because
I've talked to a lot of men that are
like I don't know what happened like I
just kind of woke up and the the guitar
was you know smashed into the wall like
and you know I hear that a lot I go from
zero to 60 and like like that like well
yeah we know from research that you know
from stimulus to response for anger it's
there's a third of a second between them
a couple hundred milliseconds well you
know people like well that's no time at
all well yes and that's enough time to
insert a thought in there of again I
need to get out of here or I need to
breathe deeply or this isn't worth it
and with practice you can extend that
third of a second to a half a second a
second five seconds that's the Repat
earning yeah and it really requires this
deep surgical operation into that 300
milliseconds yeah yeah yeah can you
really get to that point because if you
can challenge yourself to be like I can
get there I can do that then you can
take a little bit more ownership and
sovereignty over the way that we um
let's hit on some of the masks that we
have this is the mask of vulnerability
yeah and so you know the way that we're
socialized we did the ulnar ability yeah
we begin to wear masks to protect
ourselves to hide what we're actually
feeling what we're actually thinking our
hopes dreams aspirations and you know
one of the masks that we wear is this
mask of invulnerability and so we're
trained over the years to not have any
needs soar and that's the the idea of
self-reliance so men are supposed to be
self-reliant so I don't need anything
from you I can take care of it myself
directions I don't need to ask for
directions I don't need to know how to
make love I don't need to ask that I'll
just watch porn and so you know I don't
need anything I don't feel anything I
cannot be hurt so you wear this mask of
you know I guess would be the the
downside of stoicism in a way but you
know it's the we're always wearing that
mask to appear like nothing bothers us
we're balanced all those two out is so
critical but to have that that bit of
like if you do know how to get to
somewhere you can be confident and like
help someone get to that place but also
to be vulnerable and when you don't know
how to get somewhere and say like hey
can you teach me how to get to this
place I don't know and then the problem
with this is it it eliminates our
ability to ask for help when we need
help
mm-hmm yes yes and that's a problem I
mean like if you're a depressed isolated
man in his 50s and you buy into this man
box culture
you're just like I got to deal with this
on my own I got to suck it up
I gotta gut it out that's right you know
around me we love you I love Chinese
food so yeah that's the mask of
enrollment let's go to the next one okay
the mask of provider yeah and so one of
the things that one of the ways we're
socialized is to be a provider that's
one of the things we get a huge sense of
our identity that you know I'm providing
financially for the family and again if
you look at any of these ideas on a 1 to
10 scale it can be a problem if you go
too far on the extreme so if you're not
providing anything that's a problem if
you're if you become a workaholic and
you're gone from your family you know
100 hours a week that's a problem I mean
why are you working 100 hours a week
well I'm working for my family well do
you see your family no not really I'm
too tired when I'm with them and then
I'm just back to work how much sense
does that make
and and I see it all the time I I deal
with men that are worth I two hundred
million dollars or fifty million dollars
any more money that you can spend in a
lifetime and they're working a hundred
hours a week the doctor has said if you
don't find a way to manage your stress
you're going to die and they're working
now to make more money for grown adult
children that won't talk to them because
they were such a lousy father in the
past and it's like why are you doing
this
patterns and behavior and and part of it
is they they don't know who they are if
they stop yeah and they're afraid that
oh yeah it's all gonna come crashing
down catching up with them they're
afraid of depression they're afraid of
the loss of identity so yeah it's it's
it's an issue the mystery of when we
deep a turn a nun pattern and change our
behaviors of the mystery of oh I don't
know what I'm gonna become well yeah
well you know I've told them look you
were sold to build the goods and the
bill of goods go something like this get
good grades get into a good college
get a good job start making money get a
wife have kids make more money move up
the ladder and then you'll be happy and
when I see him there 50 and they're like
I'm not happy I'm miserable like what
happened
well you didn't learn the skills to
cultivate happiness you know you bought
into this this pipe dream that doesn't
pay out and that's why to me like you
know going back to that idea when I was
17 like in this idea of success where's
happiness because happiness is really to
me something we're all after I think
everyone on this planet is after
happiness and you know we go about at
different ways wealth Fame power sex
drugs serving others having a mission
but most of the ways that we go after it
or highly misguided I mean the top two
values for the younger generation are
wealth and fame whoo that's not going to
lead to their happy and not meaning and
purpose fulfillment well I think there's
it was that actually ranked by like the
Jen's ease that way that
yeah the fame dam dam because there's
also so many of them that also care
about like true yeah leaving that yeah
yeah and also like balancing these
things out is especially for for men is
really critical because you do want to
have a North Star and achieve purpose
and achieve being able to take burdens
on your back and go forth and stuff but
at the same time it's to be able to also
have that radical open honest
nerville conversation with your partners
and your families and stuff like that
well I think what a dovetail and I think
one of the things I would love to see is
men being more supportive to men I mean
think of when's the last time a man paid
you a compliment I remember I I can
think of I had a guy that I know that's
early 20s and he came in and I said why
your hair looks really nice today and
he's like [ __ ] okay so apparently you
don't take compliments very well which
is a universal for men like we don't
deal with compliments well we don't give
compliments to other men we're not
supportive to other men and this is why
we've had it like several conversations
on the show about what it's like for men
to identify women that are like you
spiritually emotionally connected and
then like men usually just go and hang
out with women that are in that capacity
because then they can open up and be
vulnerable and understand their own
emotions and feelings with women but
with men it's like yeah it's it's
literally programmed into the vibe until
you find these men that are like whoa
emotionally affected and then it's like
oh you know it makes me feel great and
so I you know going to events like that
it's fantastic okay let's hit on the
next one the mask of apathy yeah if you
want to if you're in a relationship and
you but really want to piss off your
your spouse or your girlfriend and she
asks you a question reply with whatever
or sure
and you know I think this is another way
that we protect ourselves it's it's a
non-committal response it's that I don't
care peace or I don't really have much
of an opinion so I'm not gonna go either
way and you know I think one of the
things that a lot of women want is a man
that can plan and even has an opinion on
like where do you wanna go for dinner
but you know this is one of the things
in talking with women that I hear quite
a bit and there's these little subtle
non-committal responses that we make
that can drive them a little bit nuts
yeah definitely no matter who like yeah
just responding with whatever so what
nobody cares like those words are like
oh there can harm the vibe but yeah
humans period so yeah be very vigilant
what does whatever mean is I mean yes
does it mean no yeah yeah yeah and then
the last mask of affluence yeah I think
this one really speaks to how we're
socialized in the sense that most men
are very competitive and we're always in
a constant competition of one-upsmanship
and you know I've talked to a lot of
guys entrepreneurs that you know I'll
bring up the idea of masculinity and
they're like oh no no no no I gotta have
a problem masculinity or femininity like
I'm fine like I have no problems with
masculine dating all right fair enough
like no problem and then you know few
minutes later we're talking about how he
loves going into a club with a woman
that's a 10 on his arm and I'm like so
what do you get out of that well I like
to see the other guys jealous I like him
to look at me I like him to be envious
like and you don't think that's tied
into your masculinity and then he's like
uh maybe I mean you know we're always
we're comparing by sense we're comparing
looks we're comparing you know the
sports car or how much money do you make
and we know that those upward social
comparisons when you compare yourself to
someone who's better off than you in
some way creates a feeling of being less
than
and you know to some extent misery or
people that think that somebody's last
there because they have less it's
problematic as well yeah yeah oh yeah
good point there too and then footnotes
so good on and it's it's transitioning
away from the triangle with
decentralization technologies to the
circle and it's like people that are in
positions of power right now that are
trying to clink to corruption or like
old that's old code that's dying right
now and and they're struggling yelling
screaming for power - and now
democratization of technologies are
enabling people to just be like no like
that's not happening anymore we're
moving away from that so and I think oh
yeah we were on that yeah on our way
yeah that's good and then let the last
asset explain what this is for us okay
so this is a framework that I'll teach
my clients usually the first session so
on the top half of this you've got
positive past positive present positive
future on the bottom half you've got
negative past negative present negative
future so one of the things hurt me that
I try and get across is the idea that
your mind can screw with you to put it
politely your mind isn't always your
best friend your mind isn't always on
your side that sometimes there are
voices in your head that are complete
[ __ ] honestly and you know we know
that even because we've done studies
where you you can put someone at the
edge of like the Grand Canyon and
they're looking down and it's a mile
down and if you were to step or jump
into the Grand Canyon you would die
because it's a mile down to solid rock
and inevitably most people will have
some sort of thought that says something
like jump why I mean that flies in the
face of everything we know about
self-preservation and natural selection
so we know that we have these thoughts
that don't serve us and most people
p-pardon spend most of their time on the
bottom half of this chart
so- presidents kind of a pessimistic
interpretation of the current moment and
you know if you look for the worst in
people in situations you can find it
because it's there but we know that
pessimism is closely related to
depression and irritability mm-hmm
every pessimist that I've met says the
same thing I'm not pessimistic I'm
realistic yeah yeah absolutely right
right like they're dead are accurate and
what we found is that pessimistic people
actually see reality a little bit more
accurately than optimism completely
blind optimism sure but it comes at a
cost and the cost is greater misery yeah
yeah so there's a choice and funny just
so you know you're really more miserable
or you can be more optimistic to me it's
no choice but it feels as though realism
even though it does come with that it
has a truer essence of a worldview
because it does see some of the issues
on the planet that still need to be
taking care of things like that yeah I
mean I think you can still be optimistic
and see the solutions to get out of true
yes yes you know I don't think it means
forgoing that and realism doesn't mean
having pessimism either realism can be
just realism well yeah yeah yeah so then
you know the mind kind of takes you
against your will to the negative past
bad stuff that's happened to you in the
past tragedies mistakes you've made and
we know that the more time we dwell
there the more likely we are to be
depressed and feel regret so I don't
spend a whole lot of time in the past
with my clients unless there's something
huge that needs to be that they need
help kind of finding the meaning in or
the silver lining and then the mind
takes you against your will to the
negative future so you're worrying
that's kind of the area of worry dread
stress anxiety and it's you know
imagining all the bad things that might
happen in the future and then you know
on the on the top end we know that the
more time you can spend on those top
three the more satisfied you'll be with
life so positive past is something I
don't think most of us spend a lot of
time and heard of the negative yeah yeah
but you can cultivate that skill and you
know the way to do that is with the
mental scrapbook exercise which is
simply come up with three exercise or
three memories that
each have a positive emotion attached to
them that's great the photo of my mom
holding me after she gave birth to me
like holy cow that one's been a powerful
one you know yeah or a good grade on the
test or you know a championship win in a
sport that you played or a hug that you
got or I mean for me one of them was
coming face to face with a giant sea
turtle
well that was snorkeling yeah it fills
me with awe ha that's great but you know
you can you can practice kind of
consciously mindfully pulling those
memories up and they give you a slight
emotional boost and you can post some of
them around best pictures around you're
my aces and that's huge you wake up and
you look at that and you're right away
you're revisiting positivity around you
yet that's huge and then positive
president is cultivating more
realistically optimistic mindset and
perception and that's a whole hour-long
talk that I can go into another time but
basically we know that the more you
cultivate optimism the more satisfied
you are with life and positive future
which again I don't think most of us
spend a lot of time there thinking about
where do I want to go where do I want to
be and the exercise there is called the
best possible you where you just imagine
yourself five years from now and imagine
that everything's gone as well as it
possibly could between now and then
given those conditions where would you
be in five years who would you be
hanging out with would you be married
would you know what were your friends be
doing would you be living what car would
you be driving what job would you have
and I think the more that we can focus
our mind on that sort of picture we
increase our probability of getting
there
yeah that's the future authoring yeah
yeah and taking this small incremental
steps we need to have to get there um
also just because we didn't get to the
statistic I just want to say that
another one of the reasons why you care
so much about helping men as immense
peak performance coaches because 75% of
divorces right now are being initiated
by women right and so that was an
interesting point that you told me
beforehand that I wanted to make sure
that that we at least mentioned so um
okay let's ask you a couple quick
questions on the way out John okay let's
ask do you think that we're alone in the
cosmos No
statistically I think that there has to
be some other sentient life out there I
mean we found too many planets that at
this point have the possibility of
hosting life and I think it's arrogant
to assume that we're the only ones that
are that have intelligence then what do
you think happens pre birth and post
death oh I like the idea of
transmigration of souls that and you
know I I can't prove it but I find it
comforting so I think there are things
that come up from past lives I've seen
too much to suggest that that's a
possibility post death I like to think
that there's something within us if you
want to call that soul or spirit or
energy that exists beyond us
partly because I find that a comforting
thought it's funny there's a difference
in me rationally and emotionally
rationally you know kind of the
scientist in me says oh there's no proof
for that there's no way that could be
emotionally it's a choice that I make
because it I find it comforting mm-hmm
and then do you think we're in a
simulation you know I think there's a
lot of physics that points to that as a
strong possibility I find I don't spend
a lot of time thinking about that
because my mind kind of kinks and like
stops functioning a little bit like it's
too far down the rabbit hole for me
and then what do you think is the most
beautiful thing in the world
you know I I think the most beautiful
thing in the world is positive emotions
connection relationship joy love
gratitude forgiveness compassion self
compassion yeah that laughter I mean
just that point of connection where we
can completely let down our guard and
let other people in and connect
Wow yeah carrying those with us on a
daily basis and having a world that is
just like obsessed with those emotions
would be like wow yeah I'd be totally
different totally different I love it
John this has been such a great episode
thank you thank you thank you my
pleasure on thank you thanks for having
this yeah this isn't super cool we just
love a lot to understand about how we
can get to a peak performance and and
understand the emotion feeling within
positive psychology and anger management
such a good such a good conversation
everyone thank you so much for tuning in
we'd love to hear your thoughts in the
comments below give us your thoughts
also do share more conversations with
your friends your families co-workers
online on social media get talking more
about positive psychology anger
management peak performance the
relationship between men and women that
were evolving into so get talking about
this more check out the links in the bio
below to the work of John guide to self
calm the evolved caveman calm also is
LinkedIn Twitter Instagram profiles go
and check those and follow them out and
also shout out to Ron Vargas for
producing and directing thank you very
much and support the artists
entrepreneurs the organizations around
the world that you believe in support
simulation our links are below help us
grow and prosper as well and go and
build the future everyone manifest your
dreams into the world we love you so
much thank you for tuning in and we will
see you soon peace
[Music]